se ha descrito como un desastre
ecológico toneladas de peces muertos
fueron recogidos en el río oder que
atraviesa polonia y alemania el verano
caluroso y seco en europa sumado a la
contaminación parecen ser las causas de
este dramático fenómeno
por el momento la actividad de los
pescadores es sacar todos los peces
muertos para que las aves no se los
coman y esto no se propague más los
catastro este es un desastre ecológico
en el segundo río más grande de polonia
el oder es una tragedia de los bajos
niveles de los ríos debido a la sequía
en europa podrían haber agravado la
contaminación con consecuencias nefastas
para la fauna local
[Música]
lo más probable es que alguien arrojó
algunas sustancias tóxicas al río oder
en un lugar que está más allá de los
límites de nuestra actividad y se ha
extendido por un par de kilómetros a lo
largo del río
se necesitan al menos diez años para que
el agua los peces y toda la fauna de
peces se reconstruyan este es un
desastre que no antes había sucedido y
lo sentiremos durante mucho tiempo
varios distritos alemanes fronterizos
con polonia advirtieron a los locales
que eviten el contacto con el agua del
río y no coman pescado de loder mientras
no esté clara la causa de la muerte de
los peces